Traducteur: Priscilla R. A.
Relecteur: eric vautier
Des IA, déjà, il y a quand même
une chose qu'il faut saisir :
certaines sont très anciennes.
Tous ceux qui parmi vous
ont pris des avions,
ont déjà confié leur vie à une IA.
Ça s'appelle les pilotes automatiques.
Il n'y a pas de quoi avoir peur,
ça fonctionne depuis des années,
et mieux que l'homme.
Il y a aussi eu
un nouveau changement.
Il y a des nouvelles IA qui émergent,
qui s'appuient sur
des principes scientifiques
qu'on détaillera plus tard pour que
vous compreniez les enjeux,
et qui permettent de faire
des choses extraordinaires.
Typiquement, on a fait un grand
projet avec la SNCF.
De manière très précise, grâce à ça,
vous êtes moins souvent en retard
quand vous allez au boulot
car on est capable d'anticiper des pannes
avant qu'elles ne se produisent.
On fait des choses aussi
très intéressantes avec les IA
dans le domaine de la recherche médicale.
On peut détecter des signaux faibles,
on peut analyser les causes explicatives
de récidive de cancer.
Donc, c'est une vraie
plus-value sociétale.
Pour autant, je vois aussi
qu'il y a des effets des IA
qui sont plus diffus,
moins bien connus
et qui, eux, peuvent avoir
des effets néfastes.
Mon propos ici n'est pas
de vous vendre les IA,
c'est de vous faire prendre conscience
des enjeux des IA
pour que collectivement
vous vous appropriiez le sujet
et que vous ayez envie
d'en débattre.
Alors, on a dit que le thème du texte,
c'est ouvrir la boîte,
donc, je vais vous ouvrir la boîte des IA.
Les nouvelles IA fonctionnent
sur un principe assez simple
qui s'appelle le Machine Learning.
Le Machine Learning, c'est d'envoyer
des données à un algorithme,
de lui dire :
« Cette donnée-là, tu l'apprends
à partir de cette base d'apprentissage. »
Et au bout d'un certain temps,
l'algorithme des réseaux de neurones
ou un autre type d'algorithme,
sera capable de reproduire
en conditions réelles
ce qu'il a appris avant.
On a deux techniques
en termes de machine learning.
II y a une première technique
plus classique
qu'on appelle l'apprentissage supervisé.
Typiquement, vous voulez
créer un algorithme
qui va reconnaître
des éléphants dans la savane,
vous lui envoyez 10 000 photos d'éléphants
en disant « Ceci est un éléphant »,
et puis vous lui envoyez
1 000 000 de photos de rhinocéros
en disant : « Ce n'est pas un éléphant. »
C'est ce qu'on appelle
l'apprentissage supervisé.
Ça se développe beaucoup
en ce moment,
car on a maintenant les capacités
de calcul qui permettent de le faire.
Ça s'appuie sur des réseaux de neurones
qui sont connus depuis les années 80.
Ça ne fonctionnaient pas très bien
car on n'avait pas les capacités
de calcul pour le faire.
Il y a une autre famille d'algorithmes
qu'on appelle
l'apprentissage non-supervisé.
Donc là, vous dites à la machine :
« J'ai des données,
fais-moi des calculs de distance
pour essayer de voir si
tu peux faire des regroupements. »
Ça correspond à ce que vous faites en SVT,
avec des arbres phylogénétiques.
Vous dites : « Cette population
est proche de celle-ci,
donc je les mets très proches
dans l'arbre.
Et cette population est plus loin d'elle,
donc il y a un écartement
plus fort entre les deux. »
Ça fonctionne essentiellement comme ça.
Ce n'est pas mystérieux.
Mais du coup, ça a des conséquences
qui peuvent être problématiques.
Donc, la première problématique,
c'est que les IA, c'est le titre du texte,
on peut les hacker facilement,
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut
les induire en erreur
de manière consciente ou inconsciente.
Un autre effet,
qui est aussi problématique,
c'est qu'elles sont enfermantes,
puisqu'on verra que,
travaillant par affinités,
elles ont tendance
à vous proposer
ce que vous aimez déjà
ou ce que vous lisez déjà.
Ce qui peut avoir un effet problématique
dans le débat public.
Et enfin, ces IA, on ne va pas se mentir,
vont transformer le monde du travail,
parce qu'elles vont se substituer
à certaines personnes
pour y effectuer les tâches
de traitements de données
qui jusqu'ici étaient opérées
par des personnes,
ou encore se mettre
à conduire des voitures.
Ce qui pose la question :
« Que devient le chauffeur de taxi ? »
Donc, en termes de naïveté des IA,
il y a eu une expérience assez marrante
qui a été faite par Microsoft
il y a seulement 6 mois.
Ils ont déployé une IA sur Twitter
qui était censée épouser le comportement
d'une adolescente de 16 ans.
Il s'est trouvé
qu'il y a des petits malins
qui ont détecté que
c'était une IA apprenante.
Du coup, ils lui ont envoyé des tas
de messages racistes et misogynes.
Ce qui fait qu'à la fin de la journée,
c'était plus une adolescente de 16 ans,
mais quelqu'un d'abominable.
Donc, il faut savoir qu'une IA
croit tout ce qu'on lui dit.
Vous lui dites :
« Ceci est un éléphant »,
même si c'est un rhinocéros,
elle comprendra que
c'est un éléphant.
Si on est nombreux à la hacker
en lui disant n'importe quoi,
elle va finir par dire
sérieusement n'importe quoi.
C'est un premier sujet.
Ça peut être rigolo mais en pratique,
certains détournements
sont vraiment gênants.
Il y a un autre effet :
c'est l'effet de la labellisation
des données.
Donc, pour l'apprentissage supervisé,
vous dites :
« Ceci est un éléphant,
ceci est un rhinocéros »,
tout va bien.
Maintenant, la manière dont
on labellise des données...
J'ai pris un exemple polémique
mais qui montre qu'il y a
un vrai sujet autour
de la labellisation des données.
Moi, par habitude, j'ai tendance à dire,
« Ceci est un bébé blanc,
ceci est un bébé noir ».
Mais en fait, ce faisant,
j'introduis un biais
qui tient à ma propre expérience du sujet.
Il se peut que si on pose la question
à une personne d'un autre continent,
elle me dise : « Ceci est un bébé,
ceci est un bébé blanc. »
Le problème des biais
de labellisation en entrée,
c'est que du coup l'algorithme va
épouser votre façon de pensée.
Il va donc reproduire les biais
cognitifs que vous avez.
Il va finir par amplifier le problème
que vous étiez censé corriger.
Il faut bien savoir que l'IA,
de par sa capacité à intégrer
les biais qu'on a tous,
peut aboutir à des effets assez néfastes
de renforcement de préjugés.
Il faut savoir que de manière concrète,
pour empêcher ces phénomènes-là,
des entreprises comme Amazon
font labelliser leurs données d'images
et leurs données de produits
par des gens répartis
sur les cinq continents,
en se disant :
« En prenant des gens de cultures
et de pays différents,
je vais pouvoir corriger
ce biais cognitif. »
C'est le deuxième effet néfaste :
le renforcement des biais qu'on a tous.
Ensuite, il y a un effet
encore plus gênant
qui a été pas mal abordé
depuis les récentes élections.
C'est qu'en fait les mécanismes des IA
utilisent beaucoup les mécanismes
dits affinitaires.
C'est-à-dire qu'on va reconnaître
dans la population où vous êtes
des gens pensant comme vous
et on va vous proposer des articles
que des gens qui pensent comme vous
ont trouvés bien.
Le problème de cet effet,
on ne s'en rend pas compte,
mais quand vous allez
chez un marchand de journaux,
si vous achetez l'Humanité,
vous êtes conscient
qu'il y a des gens
qui achètent le Figaro.
Sur la Terre, tout le monde est différent,
vous êtes confrontés à cette altérité
en permanence dans le monde réel.
Dans le monde digital,
c'est un petit peu différent.
Sur Facebook,
vous avez soit des amis,
soit des gens qui n'existent pas,
donc l'altérité n'existe pas.
Et le mécanisme affinitaire
vous conduit à ne lire
que des choses que vous pensiez justes
et à vous renforcer
dans vos propres préjugés.
Et ça a un effet extrêmement gênant.
C'est que du coup,
l'IA, au lieu de vous donner à penser
et de vous ouvrir des horizons,
elle vous enferme
dans votre façon de penser
ou dans la façon de penser
de votre propre groupe.
Et cette disparition de l'altérité,
ça produit des choses assez laides.
J'ai vu ça après l'élection de Trump.
C'était des Américains
de la Silicon Valley
qui s'étonnaient de n'avoir personne
ayant voté Trump parmi
leurs amis Facebook.
Comment ça se fait
vu que la majorité des gens
ont en tout cas voté Trump ?
Cet effet de bulle de renforcement
vous fait perdre de vue
qu'il y a des tas de gens
dans votre pays et autour de vous
qui ne pensent pas comme vous
et ne sont pas d'accord avec vous.
Cette disparition a un autre effet :
c'est que du coup, on peut avoir
un renforcement de croyances absurdes.
Depuis qu'on a Internet,
on voit des communautés
invraisemblables se créer.
Donc, il y a ceux qui sont persuadés
que les nuages de fumée dans le ciel
sont un complot de la CIA.
Il y a ceux qui sont persuadés
que la Terre est plate.
Les platistes sont une communauté
importante sur le net.
Il ne faut pas croire que c'est le cas
seulement de gens illuminés.
Ils sont conscients,
simplement ils se sont
enfermés dans une bulle
qui finit par leur dire :
« Autour de moi,
tout le monde pense comme moi,
donc j'ai raison de penser
ce que je pense. »
On avait un espoir.
Internet allait devenir la super
encyclopédie universelle
et la connaissance globale
allait progresser.
On se rend compte aujourd'hui
que ce n'est pas forcément le cas.
Et il y a un autre effet néfaste.
À force de vivre dans votre bulle,
quand dans le monde réel,
vous êtes confrontés à l'altérité,
ça vous fait peur.
Donc vous avez une
réaction de violence :
« Qui est cette personne
qui ne pense pas comme moi ? »
Vous n'êtes pas habitué à débattre.
Donc on trouve dans le monde digital
un nombre de débats peu constructifs,
où en gros les gens s'échangent
des noms d'oiseaux
et ça concourt à l'augmentation
de la conflictualité.
Au lieu d'avoir un débat
sain sur les questions
car vous êtes confronté
à différents avis en continu,
vous êtes enfermé dans vos bulles.
Si quelqu'un ne pense
pas comme vous,
le réflexe humain est de
prendre la massue et taper très fort
pour être sûr d'avoir raison.
Attention à l'effet enfermant.
Je ne voudrais pas
vous poser la question,
mais sur Facebook avez-vous des gens
qui ont des avis politiques
très différents de vous ?
Posez-vous la question.
Si vous n'avez dans vos amis Facebook
que des gens qui pensent comme vous,
vous êtes en train
de vous construire une bulle.
Heureusement, il y a plein de solutions
pour s'en sortir évidemment,
sinon je ne serais pas là ce soir.
Les solutions ne sont pas
si complexes à mettre en place.
D'une part, à partir du moment où
on a un algorithme de Machine Learning,
on peut faire comme
dans la recherche scientifique.
On peut demander aux opérateurs
de service de publier les données
qui ont permis de créer le modèle
et la nature du modèle
pour qu'il soit critiquable.
Est-ce qu'il y a eu un biais
dans la sélection des images ?
Ça peut se questionner.
Évidemment, on n'est pas obligé
de demander aux entreprises
de confier leurs secrets industriels,
mais on peut très bien dire :
« Après un an, vous rendez publics
votre algorithme et
vos données d'apprentissage,
pour voir s'il n'y a pas eu un biais. »
Et on regarde ça
comme un chercheur.
Donc, c'est une première chose.
Il y a une tendance en ce moment.
Il y a des mouvements
poussant à la transparence
des algorithmes.
Mais on va y venir pour
contrecarrer les effets qu'on a vus.
Il y a un autre effet :
c'est que les IA comme Tay
que vous avez vues,
ce sont des IA qui font
ce qu'on appelle de l'active learning,
c'est-à-dire qu'elle continue
à apprendre en continu.
Le problème est que celles-ci
sont très très dures.
Donc, à partir du moment où on nous met
une IA de type Active Learning,
il faut des garde-fous.
Donc, il faut qu'il y ait une
autorité de régulation qui dise :
« Vous ne pouvez pas mettre
un chatbot sur Twitter,
car il va se faire vite hacker
par une communauté de gens
pas très constructifs. »
Donc, on a besoin d'un contrôle
réglementaire à ce niveau-là.
L'autre effet qui commence
à être questionné sur Facebook,
c'est de ne pas forcément utiliser
le seul critère de la popularité
d'un article ou d'une pensée
au sein de votre groupe
pour vous le proposer.
C'est ça qui crée
des mécanismes affinitaires.
Des gens que vous appréciez
disent la même chose que vous.
Donc, ça crée de la bulle.
Donc, on peut utiliser
d'autres critères aussi
pour tempérer ces règles de classement.
On peut aussi dire :
« Cet article vient d'une source fiable,
je le remonte. »
Ou on peut dire :
« C'est un article apprécié de gens
qui ont des avis solides,
qui ne sont pas
de votre communauté
mais je vous le propose
quand même,
pour vous confronter à ce qui
se passe au quotidien »,
à savoir, si j'achète l'Humanité, d'autres
achètent le Figaro et moi, Les Échos,
et l'Alternative économique
est acheté par d'autres.
Je suis bien conscient de tout ça.
Il n'y a pas de raison que dans le
monde digital cette altérité disparaisse.
Après, il y a une question de confronter
les individus aux avis divergents.
Dans le monde digital,
si dès que vous
n'êtes pas d'accord,
vous effacez des gens sur Twitter,
vous effacez des gens sur FB,
ce n'est pas très constructif.
Et enfin, il y a eu un projet
qui s'appelle Open AI,
qui est poussé par les éditeurs de
type GAFA, des gens comme Elon Musk
qui disent : « Attention, l'IA pose
un vrai défi à l'humanité,
il faut qu'on construise
un cadre éthique autour de ça. »
En ce moment, il y a des réflexions
sur les chartes de bonne
utilisation des données,
et si les data scientists ne
devraient pas aussi avoir
un code de déontologie comme
les médecins et les avocats.
Je pense qu'on va venir à ça.
Ceci posé, on a trouvé des solutions
pour les problèmes que
je vous ai donnés là.
Mais il y a un autre problème
qui n'est pas résolu à ce stade.
Demain on aura des voitures magnifiques
qui se conduiront tout seul.
Il y aura moins
d'accidents de la route.
Au lieu de 2 000 000 morts par an
dans le monde,
on n'en aura plus que 5 000.
C'est génial !
On n'empêchera pas ça d'arriver.
Mais a-t-on pensé à
tous ceux qui vivent
aujourd'hui de l'activité de
conduire des véhicules :
ambulanciers, chauffeurs de taxi,
chauffeurs de camion ?
Ils vont se retrouver sans travail
dans un horizon de temps proche,
et ça correspond à des centaines
de milliers d'emplois en France.
Si on ne pense pas
à la transition posément,
on se retrouvera dans une situation
où des tas de gens seront des perdants,
qui seront sans travail,
et dépendront de l'assistance
publique pour vivre.
Si on n'organise pas cette transformation,
il va se passer ce qui
se passe toujours
quand des centaines de milliers
de gens perdent leur emploi :
il y aura des réactions violentes
comme des manifestations ou
des grèves assez dures,
ou l'arrivée au pouvoir de gens
pas très constructifs.
Donc là, penser cette transformation...
J'ai une petite statistique.
Les 29 États où Donald Trump
est arrivé en tête,
sont ceux où les métiers
de conducteur sont
dans les premiers bassins
d'emplois privés.
La plupart des gens ont compris
qu'ils allaient être remplacés
par des machines.
Il faut arrêter de se mentir.
Il faut faire en sorte que ça se passe
bien au lieu d'essayer de l'empêcher.
En effet, il y a plusieurs façons
de contrecarrer ce problème.
Il y a un certain
nombre d'emplois...
On peut imaginer qu'ils sont
facilement substituables.
J'imagine qu'il y a ici
une majorité d'ingénieurs.
Ce n'est pas grave de
vous dire qu'à 40 ans,
vous allez suivre des formations
pour changer de métier.
Il y a une partie de la population
qui est en capacité de faire de la
formation tout au long de la vie.
C'est une partie de la
réponse à la question.
Ça ne permettra pas de
traiter tout le monde.
Il y a une autre façon
de voir les choses.
C'est aussi de faire
la distinction entre emploi,
qui est le travail pour lequel
vous êtes rémunéré,
et le travail que vous
pouvez faire à côté.
Demain on aura sans doute des gens
qui seront des artisans,
qui travailleront dans des fablabs,
qui fabriqueront leur propre frigo,
leur machine à radio, leur ordinateur.
Ce sera pas lié à une activité rémunérée.
C'est pas un emploi,
mais c'est un travail.
Ils ne sont pas chez eux
à ne rien faire.
On va voir l'émergence aussi
d'une transformation du monde de l'emploi
vers un monde de travail,
où la rémunération ne sera pas
automatique pour les tâches effectuées.
Donc il faut repenser aussi
l'organisation de nos sociétés
autour du travail plutôt
qu'autour de l'emploi.
L'emploi, c'est ce pour quoi
vous touchez un salaire.
Le travail, ce sont les milliers
d'autres choses :
les activités de bénévolat, organisation
dans un fablab, garder des enfants,
qui créent de la valeur pour
l'ensemble de la société
et qui peuvent être considérés
comme du travail.
Donc on change un peu de paradigme,
on substitue l'emploi par le travail.
On peut aussi imaginer,
et ce n'est pas forcément choquant,
qu'on fasse des plans d'indemnisation
massive des salariés
touchés par cette transformation.
Après tout, on fera tous
des économies d'échelle.
Les voitures connectées
étant conduites toutes seules,
les taxis coûteront moins cher,
le trafic de marchandises
coûtera moins cher,
donc on en tirera
tous un bénéfice.
Il n'y a rien de choquant
à ce qu'on se dise
qu'une partie de ce bénéfice
créé par l'automatisation,
qu'elle aille pour indemniser des gens
victimes de l'automatisation.
Il n'y a aucune raison de ne pas le faire.
Enfin, et c'est tombé d'actualité,
mais ce n'était pas mon propos
au moment où j'ai lancé le TED,
c'est qu'effectivement,
il y a des réflexions en cours
dans différents pays
sur le revenu universel.
Il faut savoir qu'à l'origine,
le revenu universel était une idée
plutôt défendue par les gens
de la Silicon Valley qui disaient :
« Attention, avec ce qu'on voit
dans les labos,
on va avoir un gros problème.
Il y aura des millions
de gens sans travail.
On ne sait pas comment traiter ça,
autant se dire tout de suite
qu'on trouve les moyens
de les indemniser,
en se disant que ça permettra
de parer à l'urgence. »
C'est aussi une façon de
rémunérer le travail en se disant :
« L'emploi a disparu mais c'est pas grave,
il reste du travail. »
Donc, c'est ça, les différentes solutions.
Elles sont parfois
contradictoires entre elles.
L'une ne peut pas
forcément aller avec l'autre.
Certaines ont un prisme
politique et d'autres pas.
Mais en tout cas, ça reste possible
de penser cette transformation.
Ce qu'on ne peut pas faire,
c'est faire comme si
tout allait aller bien
et qu'on va continuer à trouver
des emplois de chauffeur livreur
parce que ce n'est pas vrai.
Il n'y aura d'emplois de
chauffeur-livreur dans 50 ans.
C'est fini,
c'est disparu.
Donc, voilà, autant penser
le monde d'après.
Donc, mon propos n'est pas de dire
que c'est extrêmement nouveau.
La solution, c'est nous,
nous tous collectivement,
qu'est-ce qu'on décide de
faire à propos de ces IA ?
Au fond, ce n'est pas la première fois que
dans l'histoire de l'humanité
on se pose des questions
sur la conséquence d'une
innovation technologique.
« Science sans conscience n'est
que ruine de l'âme » n'est pas nouveau.
Simplement, je tenais juste
à vous dire ce soir
que les IA remettent
ce vieux débat sur la table,
et ce n'est que parce qu'il y aura
un débat contradictoire
et des choix de société
qui seront faits que
ça va bien se passer.
Si on laisse le sujet
dans les seules mains
des scientifiques comme moi,
ça risque de mal tourner.
En revanche, vous pourrez m'appeler
pour trouver des solutions.
(Rires)
Voilà, je vous remercie beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)